I feel like the argument before the game
changes was you can't build as much
muscle you can't build muscle on a
plant-based diet and I think even the
naysayers have now switched to saying
okay well you can do it but it's harder
right and there's sort of some truth to
that right like especially if you've
been eating a certain way for 20 30 40
years and then you're trying to switch
that's going to be challenging right
from a habit perspective and then to be
fair
um if you just eat a bunch of steak and
eggs and bacon and milk it is easier to
get the protein in right but you don't
eat protein generally you eat food and
food comes as a package and so you've
got to worry about you know when people
talk about quality of protein to me it
would be more interesting to shift that
definition and say what does that
protein come with right does it come
with saturated fat and cholesterol and
tmao and advanced location end products
which cause cancer and or does it come
with fiber and fight the nutrients and
or folate and you know all these sorts
of things so I think the conversation
shifted from oh you can't build the
muscle it's impossible to okay you can
and there's you know there's more
research that's come out since the film
really reinforcing sort of the thesis of
the film
that was James Wilkes an elite
combatives instructor and winner of The
Ultimate Fighter best known for
producing and narrating the game
changers a critically acclaimed
documentary about the dramatic rise of
plant-based eating in professional
sports the game changers was executive
produced by James Cameron Arnold
Schwarzenegger Jackie Chan Lewis
Hamilton and Chris Paul and the film
went on to become the most viewed
documentary of all time garnering
unprecedented accreditation from the U.S
Department of Defense health and the
Academy of nutrition and dietetics
Wilkes was subsequently raided on men's
health as number three on their list of
the 13th most influential men in health
and fitness he's basically a badass
following the reefs of the game changers
Wilkes co-founded the game changers
Institute a non-profit research
educational and advocacy platform that
promotes plant forward nutrition in
order to help improve personal
performance Advanced public health and
protect the environment Wilkes also
recently executive produced eating our
way to Extinction an award-winning
documentary narrated by Kate Winslet
which addresses the dramatic impact our
food choices have on global ecosystems
we covered his plant-based advocacy
journey and what led him to the creation
of the game changers his debate with
Chris Crestor on The Joe Rogan
Experience and how the world of
Athletics has been influenced by his
film while the general public is so
confused about nutrition science and the
most frustrating thing he's seeing in
the food recommendations and Athletics
today we talked about the rise in
popularity of organ Meats collagen
intake carnivore diets protein myths and
more I had so much fun sitting down with
James for this episode but even after
the camera shut off our conversation
continued and we ended up talking about
the most layered philosophical topics
going back and forth that most people
avoid out of fear of uncomfortability
which happens to be my favorite kind of
conversation and I got to see a side of
him that reflected why he has been so
influential in his work of plant-based
advocacy he's broken a lot of narratives
because he pushes the limits of getting
to the heart of the topic at and and
he's a total go-getter James is a no BS
open-hearted intellectual full of
passion and Charisma and you just want
to keep talking to him because he's so
contemplative real and humble make sure
to watch the documentary The Game
Changers if you haven't already but you
probably already seen it and enjoy the
episode let's get into it thanks so much
for being here James I have looked up to
you and really admired your work for a
long time my husband I love your
documentary The Game Changers so I'm
honored to have you on our show no I'm
honored to be here so much yeah and I
really want to get into like you know
athletes and nutrition protein myths and
the most common misconceptions what's
frustrating about what you're seeing in
nutrition science and athletes but I
also want to talk about you know the
game changers your experience on The Joe
Rogan show so can you first start out by
telling me a little bit about your
plant-based story and what led you to
creating the game changers yeah I mean
obviously a lot of it's sort of covered
in the documentary itself you know I was
training uh for a fight injured spying
with a guy called Fabricio ver Doom who
has had about 60 or 70 pounds more
muscle than me he was uh actually went
on to win the heavyweight championship
in the UFC at one point and we were
sparring tall ligaments in both of my
knees and just you know I was two weeks
out from a fight couldn't fight
obviously
and then I thought what can I do with my
time it's going to be most productive
and that's why I thought well I've got
all these hours every day and so I
started looking into nutrition started
looking at the peer-reviewed science on
nutrition for optimal recovery and then
also athletic performance and that's
when I came across the study about the
Roman gladiators and I thought well this
can't be true you know the strontium
calcium analysis radioisotope analysis
basically on Earth you know 5 000
Gladiator bones that were analyzed and
it was suggesting that they almost
exclusively plants and I thought well
you need meat for muscle is what I
thought and you need vary for bones how
can that be true and so that wasn't
enough to convince me obviously but that
was enough to start really digging into
the research and more and that's when I
sort of contacted the head of nutrition
at Harvard they had an apology at
Harvard the president of the American
College of Cardiology the lead delegate
of Urology for the American Medical
Association and all of these experts and
that's what sort of turned into the game
changers documentary
that's awesome I remember that part
about the Gladiators in the documentary
that was something presented that I
never heard before and like I've been
plant-based for you know 15 years and
I'm like I have never heard something
like that yeah and contemporary they
were known as horiz which means the Bali
men's they were known for reading a lot
of Bali and just a lot of plant foods
and did and did you go plant-based
overnight or was it like a gradual
transition for you no I didn't I didn't
sort of make the decision okay I'm going
plant-based um I was sort of gradually
shifting you know cutting out animal
products uh slowly with cutting out meat
first and then
um and then eggs and then fish and dairy
um over sort of six week period and then
I thought well now I'm gonna go I'm
gonna try going completely plant-based
and see what happens and that's when my
endurance improved as you saw in the
documentary you know doing the battling
ropes for an hour the most I'd ever done
before was eight minutes
and then what I didn't show in the
documentary is you know my strength went
up as well so uh bench press on
dumbbells for example and for some
people this sound like a lot and some
people won't always depends on it's all
relative uh but I went from 105 pound
dumbbells in each hand
um dumbbell press for five reps to 115
pounds in each hand for six reps within
just a few weeks so right it really had
a big uh impact on me yeah yeah and that
was a similar transformation for my
husband too because when he he had the
same kind of misconceptions about meat
and protein and and athleticism and so
when he went plant-based he's like just
found himself with so much more energy
and a desire to work out he's like I
think I'm gonna go for a run today like
and he never was in that position that's
when he read Rich roll's book and
everything just took off from there
because it was just undeniable yeah
that's one of the things you know
because some people say oh it was
because people started working out more
but you know
um uh a friend of us who helped get the
film onto Netflix for us he actually
wants to implant makes it just felt like
they had more energy right and so then
he was able to start looking out more
and then he lost 40 pounds yeah of fat
right yeah it was just like a natural
desire he's like I just want to get up
and go move my body just got more energy
yeah totally so I was listening to
another interview that you did talking
about the game changers being what is it
like one of the most popular review
documentaries I mean on all accounts it
seems to be the most viewed documentary
of all time
um with over a conservative estimate of
100 million views so Netflix doesn't
actually give us numbers and then we're
on Yoku in China which is twice as 800
million viewers in China on Yoku and
between those two platforms and the
other platforms are on like iTunes and
Google Play and Vimeo and so forth we've
also had some research done with Nielsen
uh you know which can sort of assess how
many people have been watching it at
least in America and it seems that at
least over 100 million people we had
over 1.5 billion media Impressions
including 40 000 over 40 000 organic uh
press articles written about the film
and according to Google Trends uh
interest in plant-based email more than
tripled worldwide within two weeks wow
of the film's release and recently just
in the last few months we had a
Consulting analyst from Merrill Lynch
look at sort of the trends since 2004
and it showed that 75 of the increased
interest in plant-based eating since
2004 was a direct result of the film so
wow it seems by far it's the single most
impactful sort of
media piece of media or program or you
know whatever to shift people towards
more plant-based eating and it makes
complete sense because like you were
saying somewhere else about how prior to
the film it was like eight out of ten
plant-based eaters were were women and
after the film that shifted dramatically
and sent so much of our choices when in
how we eat and the lifestyles we live is
directly related to our social and
cultural relations in life like if your
partner is suddenly starting to be
interested in something that he wasn't
interested in before it makes sense how
it's going to create a much bigger boom
and like a more like consistent
long-term like a sustainable sustainable
way to eat because you have other people
around you that's doing it now and it's
like a ripple effect yeah I mean I think
before you know the messaging around
plant-based eating was more around
compassion for animals and environment
both of those things were important but
I think that would appeal more to women
generally and actually a lot of the
behavioral psychology research shows
that with the compassionate messaging
and caring about animals in the
environment government a lot of young
men are insecure about their masculinity
and compassion is synonymous with
femininity and so there's actually some
research done on this where men in the
short term when they see that kind of
messaging will eat less meat will
actually end up eating more than they
originally were later on because they're
trying to overcompensate for sort of
feeling a bit too compassionate and so
obviously messaging and the game
changers was quite different as you said
8 out of 10 vegetarians vegans
plant-based eaters were female before
the film we just had a survey done in
the US
um one in I think it was one in 14 women
uh one in 10 people overall and one in
seven men had actually seen the film in
the United States and they were totally
switched so it was like a two to one
male to female ratio of the respondents
that were a now eating plant-based so
yeah it was pretty exciting that is so
cool that's so rad because I mean the
notion of like masculinity and eating
meat goes back so long I did an episode
with um Dominic Thompson
that was a really great one talking
about veganism and masculinity and he
had some really fascinating points about
how like um being this notion of hunting
and killing animals and eating lots of
meat and how we think that's masculinity
when really it's much more masculine to
be a protector right and so if we could
shift that like greater understanding of
what does it even mean to be have that
masculine energy like being a protector
makes much more sense yeah totally
anyway yeah I don't typically buy into
the gender Norms right but as
traditional men yeah I think that's why
athletes firefighters and soldiers in
the film appealed that you know to
people
um and then yeah as you're right I think
that comes from sort of provider and
protector and for provider you know back
in the day like what else are they
providing other than meat right which is
funny because uh men women and children
um you know in foraging societies are
actually producing uh much more of the
calories around 80 of the calories and
then the men were doing much more work
um and hunting didn't even become
remotely efficient until about 30 to 60
000 years ago with the Advent of the bow
and arrow right it was extremely
inefficient before then and even then
they weren't really catching much of the
calories and so I think they felt like
they needed to celebrate and there were
sort of celebrations around hey we've
caught this meat but really they weren't
providing a majority of the calories the
men and women and children were yeah
that's so interesting and it makes so
much sense that when men are watching
this documentary or and women too but
you know generally more appealing to men
like you were saying that they're like
oh yeah it's all great and good that you
know eating plant-based is good for the
environment you know kinder to animals
but like how am I gonna how how's my
strength gonna be how's my athleticism
going to be here and so that film just
totally spoke to people and yeah even
even the health message actually is sort
of um it sort of affects different
people in different ways so once people
are older they start caring more about
their diabetes or heart disease risk or
their friends are dying from something
and then they start caring but actually
for for young people especially young
men
um there's this sort of an additional
backfire effect
um based on something called the
handicap principle in evolutionary
biology which manifests
both physically for example with um
peacocks they say that large feathers
are basically the male trying to say hey
I've got all these beautiful feathers
which are hard to carry around but I'm
such like a masculine peacock that I
can't uh I haven't been eaten by
Predators but it also
um the handicap principle manifests
um behaviorally also so you tell a young
man to stop smoking for it's because
it's bad for him or to stop eating meat
because it's bad for him
he actually will tend to do more of it
again a backfire because he's trying to
demonstrate that things that affect
other people won't affect him because
he's got better genes and he's more
alpha male oh my God yeah so depending
on who you're trying to reach right
you're going to want to give a different
message older people
um are going to care more about their
health and younger people and so you
know when it comes to Performance like
the athletic performance or sexual
performance or performance at work
that's going to resonate more with the
other people and especially with with
men in general again generalizing there
yeah and another random example is like
I've spoken to some men before who have
had vasectomies and they're like it
would be so cool if like I was the one
that could still get my partner pregnant
even with the vasectomy like it didn't
work on me type of thing that's like
another another prime example yeah for
sure totally so with this huge amount of
people watching it reviewing it
critiquing it also is going to come with
a lot of criticism and you know how did
that feel to even have people attempting
to to debunk your film in like an hour
in like half an hour or an hour that you
put your whole life work into
um the reason why I asked that is
because I watched your entire debate
with uh Chris Crest Around The Joe Rogan
Experience because I love debates I love
listening debates they're like my
favorite thing ever and you just totally
crushed it and I was telling everyone I
know like you've got to wash this
docular watch this uh debate
um with James Wilkes so like how did
that feel I mean you expressed that in
the conversation of like look you tried
to like debunk my film in the last
episode maybe you can explain for people
who didn't who don't know about this
conversation what happened with that
yeah I mean like just going back it was
you know there was quite a lot of people
that were just putting out articles
trying to Cherry they were actually sort
of saying that we were cherry picking
even though we were using the proponents
of evidence we were you know
interviewing like one of the criticisms
of some of the plant-based films is that
they don't include like high level
experts in all the different fields but
I mentioned some of the experts that we
had earlier and then just looking at the
performance evidence and the large
um you know the who the FAO the academy
nutrition dietetics all recommending
plant predominant or plant exclusive
diets
um but we did get some pushback but
there was there was never any great
arguments um against the film that I
couldn't you know I couldn't argue
against
um and it was frustrating Christopher
said I spent seven hours doing this I
was thinking I spent seven years making
this film right and um unfortunately
couldn't put all of we had 600 hours of
footage we couldn't put it all into the
film tons of great experts that didn't
even make it into the film unfortunately
um The Joe Rogan episode
um it was funny I had people on social
media on Instagram say hey I saw your
film I got plant-based and then you know
a few months later they're like I just
watched the Chris cressa episode and you
were lying and I've switched back to
Reading meat
and then after director episode that
same person
oh I'm sorry you know I shouldn't have
taken but you know when I sat there and
watched the Chris cressa episode which
we tried to get on by the way you know
to debate him like live the first time
when Chris Kresser went on and did a
three-hour and to be clear for anyone
watching like or listening to this that
that Joe Rogan had on Chris Kresser to
basically debunk the game changers film
without you there yeah I tried to get on
that was the first I didn't want to get
myself on again I don't really think
that I'm an expert so I try to put on a
uh Chief science advisor David Goldman
who has a double master's degree in
exercise physiology and nutrition right
councils a lot of uh Olympic Matt gold
medalists and you know football players
and and just really been in the space
for a long time Real Genius in terms of
nutrition and athletic performance and
so I tried to put him forward for that
first episode with Chris cresser again
Chris cresser is advocating for sort of
more of a paleo-ish type of diet and he
always says that he has Master's
training in nutrition what he means is
that there was one nutrition class I
think in his master's degree in what is
that he's a uh what is the qualification
into your room I don't remember but I
heard you say acupuncture and he never
mentions that on Joe Rogan so nothing
not them saying anything positive or
negative about acupuncture but it's not
his field of expertise just like I don't
feel like it's mine you know I but when
I made the film I'd read over a thousand
hours of peer review search I've now
read a little over three thousand and
people call BS on that but it's just I
just I'm a little bit OCD and so I just
read and read and read yeah yeah I
really enjoy you know the information
um but yeah he's on seven hours and I
sat there thinking if I didn't know what
I know I would have been actually quite
convinced by you know Chris's arguments
um and so that week leading up to the
Joe Rogan episode where I Joe uh kindly
gave me the chance to debate Chris
Kresser after that first episode yeah
after the first episode so I went back
on the second time Chris was on it was a
debate with myself and again I tried to
put David Goldman or someone else
forward to debate
um that has you know degrees in
nutrition and exercise but they wanted
me on I said okay fair enough yeah
because that's not as clicky like
they're like who's David Goldman yeah
yeah
[Music]
um and so to be honest I don't think I
did a great job in the first 45 minutes
I picked a topic that wasn't great Joe
was really on his side yeah it was sort
of two on one and I didn't pick the best
topic to argue um you know Chris
Crestwood misquoted an article he made
his own quote right by adding up some
figures and then he put quotes on it and
then put the name of the article
underneath anytime you see quotations
like that it really should be
referencing the article itself but it
was his own quote but he made out it was
a quote from the article and so I picked
that and it was a little bit nitpicky
that was awesome still it's still valid
it's valid but it wasn't the best
argument
um you know it was something like where
you know 60 something percent of studies
showed no effect 12 to positive 12 and
then he'd added the 60 and the 72 saying
something like this saying oh they
showed a negative effect right
um You just counted that point but it
was just his own quote and he sort of
made up his statistic
um I went in a little bit too amped up
and I was sort of like I felt like I was
going in for a fight honestly
um well I mean it kind of is you're like
defending what your life's work yeah
exactly but I think I was a little bit
amped up and probably but anyway you
know after about the 45 minute Mark
where unfortunately I think a lot of
people who are really in the meeting and
anti-plant-based diets already stopped
watching by then uh but if people watch
the whole thing I think you'll see
um that I fairly won I mean even Joe
Rogan right who's relatively you know
usually pretty anti-plant-based diets
said that I didn't lose a single
argument so yeah I mean I definitely saw
that I saw on his page he's like vegan
he did a post when you're the episode
about vegans you're gonna love this one
like I think James something about James
like proving me wrong or at least like
you know and I'm like what so I went and
watched the entire thing in clips and
clips I watched it yeah other people
like really anti-legmist saying oh Joe
must be trolling people there's no way
yeah yeah at first it felt like that
yeah at first I was thinking why did he
say that yeah but by the end I think it
was clear on on protein quality on
protein quantity on you know
um B12 on a whole range of things and I
wasn't much prepared for I only covered
about 15 20 of what we wanted to cover
um and I had a lot more arguments you
know from from environmental stuff to
crop deaths to all sorts of stuff that I
was and a lot of stuff across health and
athletic performance I was cover but we
didn't get to it and after the
conversation was there any kind of
consensus between you and Chris in any
form
no he still stands by yeah you know he
stands by
um his arguments he tries to put down my
arguments
um I could have done a better job like
he started listing off some things
showing that uh meat didn't have an
impact on like arterial disease and at
the time in the episode I didn't realize
that those studies were on racks uh that
he was just suddenly bringing up out the
blue because it's kind of challenging
when you haven't had a chance to see I
think a real debate both sides should
share their sources you know beforehand
right and then maybe have another
passive oh okay you want to address that
and then come up with more sources and
share those and then have the debate yep
um but Chris would try a whole bunch of
stuff
um you know right on
you know some things that affect mice
don't affect rats and vice versa so
think of the difference between like
right you know rats and mice and humans
right that's a big big difference
definitely weak evidence yeah yeah
compared to what it can be for sure yeah
so how are receptive are people nowadays
after the film do you feel like to
plant-based diets athletes I think it's
still a mix you know I think the um
I think they're still a mix but I think
there's a general shift I feel like the
argument before the game changes was you
can't build as much muscle or you can't
build muscle on a plant-based diet and I
think even the naysayers have now
switched to saying okay well you can do
it but it's harder right and there's
sort of some truth to that right like
especially if you've been eating a
certain way for 20 30 40 years and then
you're trying to switch that's going to
be challenging right from a habit
perspective
um and then to be fair
um if you just eat a bunch of steak and
eggs and bacon and you know milk it is
easier to get the protein in right but
you don't eat protein generally you eat
food and food comes as a package and so
you've got to worry about you know when
people talk about quality of protein to
me it would be more interesting to shift
that definition say what does that
protein come with right does it come
with saturated fat and cholesterol and
tmao and advanced glycation end products
which of course cancer and or does it
come with fiber and fight the nutrients
and or folate and you know all these
sorts of things so
um I think the conversation shifted
between from oh you can't build the
muscle it's impossible to okay you can
and there's you know there's more
research that's come out since the film
uh really reinforcing sort of the thesis
of the film so for example in 2021 in
the Journal sports medicine there was a
12-week Interventional study where they
put people on plant-based diets and
supplemented with a bit of soy protein
to bring it up to 1.6 grams of protein
per kilogram of body weight and then
they did an animal based or sort of an
omnivorous diet where they supplemented
with whey protein to bring it up to 1.6
so 1.6 grams per kilogram which seems to
be the sweet spot
the vast majority of people to build to
maximize muscle mass there was no
differences over after the 12-week
period and that was an Interventional
study it wasn't just observational
and then in terms of health just
recently this year in 2022 Harvard
researchers published findings from the
million veterans study that showed that
those eating the most plant-based Foods
had a 25 or 25 less likely to die during
the whole study period it went on for
years and those who ate the most whole
plant Foods right so not just plant
foods but whole plant Foods had a 36
decreased
likelihood of dying during the study
period so again it's not just the
research that came before the film
there's just more research coming out
both from athletic performance and
muscle burning standpoint and from a
health standpoint
um just reinforcing the thesis from the
film yeah and that's why you know like
you said earlier if anybody had watched
the Chris cresser first episode with Joe
Rogan that and didn't know anything else
like that you knew from all the studying
that you've done it would be easy to be
like oh okay yeah he's right he's on to
something the problem is crap or
whatever but that's why listening to
both sides is so in integral to
understanding really what is the truth
here and I think that's so true when it
comes to debates like being able to
present your resources so you can yeah
it's actually worked out better than
that we didn't debate in the first one
because you presented information which
was just like totally disprovable so so
for example like oh
um cattle and never fed any B12 they get
it yeah I can just show you a whole
bunch of like his products they're for
sale here's the top like research
company saying you know a lot of uh
catalog and b12 so there was just so
many things that you could just easily
disprove just with a few minutes you
know uh looking at the research yeah a
lot of people if they had just listened
to that first one wouldn't know any and
or maybe just even in the future don't
take the time to listen to this other
viewpoint on this other side all this
new research even that's coming out
still today they wouldn't know any of
that stuff and yeah it's easy to have
tunnel vision yeah with Chris it was
crazy like so you know we said that up
to 39 of people are low in B12 and most
of those are meat eaters right and he
said all that study you know you never
gave a citation so I screen capped the
film the citation was there on the
bottom and it turns out it was the very
first citation in his own book on B12 so
he'd used the same study and then said
that that study that we never cited it
and it doesn't exist and you know then
he uses all these oh it just Cherry
Picked the data basically wow do you
feel like the general response like like
you knowing how you feel after you feel
the general response was that you people
understood where you're coming from by
the end of it if they watched the whole
thing yeah
um I think so in fact if you look at
Google Trends you can see the spike
interest after the film in Palm Bay
seating and then you see another another
Spike right after the Joe Rogan wow
episode obviously he's got a massive
reach he has so much influence yeah wow
that's amazing yeah it is great in some
ways but I think he's a bit you know he
Joe is pretty open-minded in most ways
but I honestly feel like when it comes
to nutrition I feel like it's a lot of
it is based on his identity and so like
hunting and going back to this masculine
uh sort of energy and feeling the need
to be a provider and so forth right but
I guess we're all biased in some way I
feel like I feel like he does a pretty
good job bringing on all sides on all
kinds of topics like for like it's
pretty hard I feel like to do it like
super balanced all the time right he
does but someone has reviewed um how
many of people did not believe how many
of the nutrition experts that Joe has
had on that don't believe that saturated
fat as indicated in how atherosclerosis
and heart disease which it very clearly
is by like a whole number of measures
not just people are always saying that
um you know planets are disappointing
towards observational studies which
don't prove causation but when it comes
to saturated fat and have elevated
cholesterol and elevated LDL that's been
done in metabolic Wards right which is
the the best intervention that you can
do where everything is measured
everything that goes in everything goes
out and it's been shown like thousands
of times that's the case yeah it's
really really clear but at the same time
I can't really blame him but that's as
bias because I have on more plant-based
people than I do yeah that makes sense
yeah that's true but it would be super
cool to see like more I would love to
see more debates like on his show for
sure okay so let's move on next thing I
want to ask you is why is the general
public I mean you're not going to know
the answer but the general public is so
confused about nutritional science and
diet and arguments about other there's
so many arguments so what is your take
on in perspective on why that is yeah I
mean first of all nutrition is hard to
study right because
you you you're basically going to take
sort of uh studies
um that look at things in a in a Petri
dish or in a lab and then you look at
observational studies epidemiological
data which can sort of you know give
hypotheses and sort of make suggestions
around what what the truth is
um
but
again it doesn't show causation
necessarily and then you can look at
Interventional studies but the thing is
we can't do long-term Interventional
studies right you can't put people you
know you can't put people on for 40
years right in 50 years and say you've
got to eat this and track them and those
impossible
um so first of all it is difficult
um to really test you know what for sure
is causational right so that's tricky
number two unfortunately there's a lot
of influence from industry in the
studies right so there's a lot of
funding that goes on
um and then number three
you know the media doesn't really
present the studies
as accurately as they should be so I
remember seeing one study saying oh
vegans didn't do so well so I looked at
it and the vegans were eating fish so
right so like the media just if you just
read the headline in the media yeah
which is what most people do yeah so
that and again I understand that because
most people aren't going to spend a
thousand hours reading peer-reviewed
science I just don't have the time or or
the background education in order to do
so
um so it is challenging and I don't know
really what the answer is what we do
know now though is the largest
organizations like I was mentioning
earlier the FAO The Who The Academy
nutrition dietetics are all saying that
we should be eating predominantly or
exclusive plant-based diets
um and then you know the camera
dietetics says that vegan diet
completely vegan diet is safe for all
um
stage of the life cycle right from
pregnancy to infancy to adolescence
including for athletes you know and
older people and so
um yeah I think it's it's very clear
like now
to eat a predominantly plant-based diet
right a vast amount of your calories
coming from plants like there's just no
question and the evidence is very robust
right now to say well is there a benefit
to going 100 versus 95 I still think
that there's evidence right strong
enough evidence for me to eat 100 but
that strength of 95 to 100 isn't the
same as like going from 50 to 95 right
yeah and so our Approach at the game
changers Institute which is our
non-profit it's a research education
advocacy platform is to say it's all or
something not all or nothing right and
so a lot of people just aren't going to
go all in anyway and it can be quite
daunting to think I'm committing to
switching completely and so the science
really going to show both for the health
and for the environment is like any
shift towards eating more plant-based
especially more whole plant Foods is
going to be beneficial right and so I
think if you say it's it's very black
and white it's vegan or it's not and I'm
going to judge you if it's not that's
that's pretty challenging and so yeah
the evidence is pretty clear I know it
can be confusing but eating
predominantly plant-based or preferably
exclusively plant-based is definitely
the way to go yeah and it does seem like
correcting by wrong that it's way more
common now for professional athletes to
be seeing massive benefits from going
plant-based through their recovery and
their performance it seems a lot more
common now yeah it seems more common um
I think it is more common and we're
doing an approach to The Institute with
a lot of Olympic medalists and NFL MBA
and players asking for help one of the
things that was interesting when we made
the film is that we noticed that team
players were a lot less likely to
mention it even if they were plant-based
they could sort of a peer pressure
whereas individual athletes would be
more outstanding I mean uh in team
sports we would find that they were
hiding like the Amy's burritos or
something at the bottom of the freezer
right because there was a bit of a
stigma and I think that since the game
changes that stigma has changed and
people are recognizing that you can have
uh at least as good if not improved
athletic performance yeah
and that just goes back to the impacts
of Social and cultural experiences and
how much it's going to affect people's
decisions or maybe how loudly they're
gonna or just be comfortable in the fact
that they're doing that no so what is
the most frustrating thing that you're
seeing in the world of athletes and food
recommendations that you're seeing today
yeah I mean I think you know it went
from one thing which was like the paleo
diet right and it was interesting about
the paleo diet is actually what happens
people do uh get improvements going on
the paleo diet switching from the
standard American diet there's this
weight loss cholesterol can come down
what's super interesting at the time we
made the film The Longest study ever
done on uh sort of where they followed
up was for two years on the paleo diet
and what was interesting is they were
actually doing much more plant-based
diet than they were before so they're
cutting out Dairy they're cutting out
um refined you know
heavily processed foods
um refined foods and then they're
increasing the amount of fruits and
vegetables and the one thing actually
they didn't stick with on the
recommendations was increased meat
consumption so they did early on there
was a spike in in more meat and then it
just dripped down naturally people just
didn't stick to the recommendations that
they were given so really they were
again cutting out refined cutting out
Dairy eating more fruits and vegetables
and whole plant Foods so no wonder they
you know they've got a benefit but
what's it sort of shifted from that
paleo into even even more meat heavy
diet right on the extreme end you've got
the carnivore favorite diet where
they're eating only meat and then
especially with the organs right livers
are kidneys and brains people are
sometimes just eating that now that can
have some benefits in the short term
because it's like any exclusion diet
right where you're you know for example
if you just cut out Dairy out of your
diet you can see improvements uh you
know in gastrointestinal health and
um you know so
of course by just eating one thing
you're cutting out some of the things
that could be bothering you right but in
the long term
um it does not look good right if you're
just eating a whole bunch of meat and
then um you know with the heavy metals
and the organs and so forth you're just
missing out on you know fiber for
example which is really important to gut
health so what could be the problems
then of eating so many organ meats or
even just such a meat heavy diet like
what are you what have you seen based on
the research you've done yeah well I
mean so so there's not any really
long-term studies on the carnivore only
diet there has been some people that
have followed some of the things are uh
is sugar in the urine because the
saturated fat helps clog up with insulin
receptors right and then you just can't
handle any uh you can't really can't
handle the sugars at all and so
um increase risk for diabetes right and
then the urine is much more acidic and
lower acid diets have been shown to have
benefits for uh both Health right more
alkaline diets for health and also
frustrating performance
um and I think there should be more
long-term well should that I don't think
it would be like ethical to put people
on an Interventional right if you just
want to follow someone that's doing it
you could look at more of that
um research which just doesn't really
exist yet but you're just missing out on
um you know missing out on fiber and all
the phytonutrients and everything else
that come with it and and again the
saturated fat you know the Dodge
guideline advisory committee uh in the
United States says to keep saturated fat
you know 10 or below
to keep your heart disease risk down
that's typically going to be much higher
on um
you know on uh on a
carnivorous diet right and then you're
seeing people started switching from you
know even even when I was fighting uh
people said they were on the paleo diet
and then they were drinking a ton of
Gatorade I'm like well how is that paleo
like well I get tired otherwise I don't
really have the energy it's like exactly
because you're missing out on all all
the carbs right you're having to do with
sugar like before and after now because
you're not getting it from you know a
wider variety of fruits and vegetables
and whole grains and legumes and so
forth
um so you're starting to see some people
shifting out from carnivore into you
know adding some fruit or honey and that
type of thing so that I think they're
recognizing okay we need to get some
some carbs some kind of yeah fresh carbs
yeah and there's whole sort of another
thing that bothers me not just from a
health perspective
but it's from an environmental
perspective this sort of claim that um
holistic grazing is part of regenerative
agriculture is beneficial for the
environment which is just clearly not
right so white oak pastures is one of
the ones that sort of point to as an
example
um being a sort of natural sustainable
Farm producing grass-fed beef first of
all they've even said that it's not
replicable at Large Scale right you just
wouldn't have enough people would have
to eat a lot less meat if they were
going to eat this way like a lot less
yeah they're advocating for way more
meat that's interesting yeah just it
doesn't make sense there's not enough
land on the planet right number one uh
number two it's funny that they say it's
a sustainable Farm
um in 2017 they sued the federal
government because the American bald
eagles killed 130 000 of their chickens
um because you know I even I used to
think that chickens roaming around on
the grass in the open plane was natural
but chicken a jungle foul right so they
should have coverage
recovered to protect them from predators
but they're all roaming around down of
course the Farmers can't kill the
American bald eagle because it's
protected yeah and so um they sued for
2.2 million dollars in 2017. it's just
it's not really a sustainable way of um
of farming
it couldn't happen at Large Scale
um and then this sort of argument about
sequestering uh methane uh by you know
moving the cattle around
um has some short-term benefits it
doesn't offset actually the uh the
detrimental um the cows are causing but
it does mitigate it somewhat but it's
also temporary as well so again not my
sort of strength of expertise to cover
and there's great folks like Nicholas
Carter yeah I really want to get them on
yeah I'm seeing them this weekend and so
you know it would be great to cover
cover something like that you should
mention me and be like do you want to
come on sure yeah because I would love
to get on actually I would love to do
like a a debate episode on like um
animal Ag and the environment versus
like plant advocate for the environment
that would be such a good one because
you really see both passionate people on
both sides that are like so passionate
about it but it to me I'm just like a
very simple mathematical sense it does
not make sense for to increase our
animal foods and and to do grass-fed for
like free range all the stuff like like
just not taking into account the amount
of land it's just not possible to
sustain the world yeah and the thing is
those studies where it's shown sort of
um
a benefit for the environment have not
been peer reviewed when there is right
it's just like
it's funny because
um epic bars which is owned by General
Mills uh General Mills helped fund the
study and then they're also the number
one purchaser of the the beef that comes
from whale pastures so you also got to
look at like yeah the motivations behind
why they're putting that stuff out yeah
for sure and even just taking something
like back to the organ Meats like the
amount of organ meats that are being
advocated now in these circles take
something very specific like liver like
it's considered now like a superfood in
some of these like high animal food
based circles and if everybody ate the
amount of liver that every that they're
advocating for you know how many cows
whole cows would have to die for the
liver like like literally for the liver
we'd have to it just it just does not
make sense yeah yeah for the amount okay
so that is really great I love that
um I'm trying to think what the next one
is like in regards to the age-old
question like where do you get your
protein that's something but now it's
kind of switched to
um well it's not as bioavailable and
from Plants yeah yeah so just going back
again like I said before I think you
know it is more challenging right
because like plant Foods if you look at
plants overall they are low in protein
they're like steak or eggs and so forth
right and so you do have to be more
cognizant I think so that's the first
thing it's been more comes in make sure
you're getting like legumes nuts and
seeds right and then if you want protein
powders right you don't have to do them
but it makes it an easier way to get
them in uh for athletes that are really
trying to maximize muscle mass yeah um
and so yeah the bioavailability is the
sort of second question okay you can get
enough protein but it's not as available
um so the first of all you know there's
the PD cast which is the protein
digestibility amino acid score which is
the the score that's most widely used
now
um for protein uh quality and
digestibility and then there's one that
came out in the last 10 years or so
which hasn't been as adopted but it's
there's a little bit better job called
the DS which is the digestible
indispensable amino acid score
um it's funny because the dairy industry
helped fund that and a surprise surprise
um the maximum level used to be one and
so Dairy and soy and you know meat were
all at one and now the DS score allows
Dairy to go above one right
um
and there's a bunch of issues with the
with the protein scoring system so
number one
um well first of all they were they were
put in place by the FAO and The Who and
they looked at for children particularly
two-year-olds and under in developing
countries and what their protein
requirements are that's sort of how it
started right and so people somehow in
the developed world have taken this
program this went for you know people
are getting very little protein very
little diversity of foods
in developing countries and they've
somehow translated it like what we need
here right in in a developed world where
you can go to the grocery store and get
like a whole wide variety of whatever
you want and again enough calories right
so it was to solve quashier core which
is protein deficiency
right and this is not a single case that
I'm aware of in the United States of
anyone with question court if you're
eating enough calories right so if
you're eating enough calories you're
getting enough protein and then in terms
of the quality the scoring system uh
isn't for developed world it's not for
people it's not to do with muscle
building right people have just sort of
taken it because it's the best thing you
can do the second thing is that it's
analyzed in rats and pigs primarily
right which have they grow at much
faster rates they do it in adolescent
pigs right and that's they've got
totally different you know acid
requirements
um the one benefit of the DS protein
scoring system is it looks at oro oro
digestibility so pdcast looked at like
the full digestive tract right and the
DS program looked at like for the
protein from the mouth to the ilium
because past the ilium and so they put
pretty gross they basically dig a hole
in the pig at the ilium and put a port
in so they can see what came out because
with the old protein scoring system you
would look at you know the full
lenphagos retract but some of that
protein was getting ingested by bacteria
and not by people right not by the human
gut does that make sense so the protein
scrolling system is off
um another problem with it is that they
feed raw
um like raw powdered foods to the pigs
well
I mean most people cook their beans
right because if you don't yeah they're
they're not good for you right yeah and
so if you feed raw legumes and raw
grains
um to to pigs and assess that there's
very different there's something called
trypsin Inhibitors which inhibits the
protein absorption right
um and so if you cook food that changes
things dramatically and so the studies
actually in humans that they've looked
at and you can look at the ilium in
humans you have to put a nasal tube down
into the ilium
um digestibility is actually higher in
plant Foods than some animal Foods so
Lupine for example which is a legume has
around 90 percent or so digestibility
and it's higher than egg which is
yielded as like one of the key protein
you know Foods out there
um and so the percent difference is not
like 50 to 90 like people used to think
it's really a couple of percent
difference
and what really matters is people are
always looking at these these tiny
differences but what matters is what the
actual outcomes are and the outcome is
if you're eating 1.6 grams per kilogram
of protein as a general recommendation
for most people you build as much muscle
now some people need less and they'll
need more if you're in a clock deficit
right you're trying to lose body fat but
still again or maintain or gain muscle
you need a little bit more protein
perhaps up to 2.2 grams per kilogram of
body weight
but if you look at the outcomes that
you're actually interested in right
there's really no difference in in
muscle gain between the two and I would
argue that there's better athletic
performance advantages to having you
know more carbs
um you know lower information better
endothelial function right more blood
flow those things that affect acidic
performance in the short run but also
affect Health in the long run yeah that
that's why I love the book whole we're
thinking the science of nutrition with
the nutritional biochemist T Colin
Campbell like that is one of my favorite
books because he really breaks down and
explains the difference between
reduction in science versus holistic
holistic science and the importance of
that and so often you can just see a
headline like you know with a story like
you said and it's like it could be very
reductionist science compared to like
what's the holistic outcome of those
Whole Foods and you brought up such good
points about the industry funding that
happens in science in America at least
specifically especially it's funny how
there's a little bit of a group in kind
of this group we've been talking about
thinking that there's almost the
opposite effect that there's like an
agenda for to get people to eat vegan or
plant-based and it's going to make
everybody sick as if there's industry
funding for like brought big broccoli or
something there's no big broccoli but
there's definitely big AG like big Dairy
no I mean I think when it comes to
industry-funded studies of course that's
often going to happen because they're
trying to see like you know if it's
beneficial or is it no and so I don't
think you could paint a it's not black
and white again where you say oh it's
industry funded therefore it's garbage
yeah I think when it is industry fundage
industry funded it takes you want to
look at it with a little bit more
scrutiny yeah
um and you know if somebody there is an
agenda just whatever the agenda is but
this idea that it's a conspirate
governatorial conspiracy to make people
weaker or something yeah it's just yeah
so what about collagen that's something
else that's a really hot topic in the
athletic nutrition world or not even
just athletic but you know yeah and both
but I think there's two points of I mean
not two points of view there's two
reasons people who are in collagen I
think
one we know that like a big motivation
for people's diets is Vanity right and
so for skin and nails and hair and this
type of thing people are eating um
eating a lot of collagen hair in fact
there's more like 95 keratin I believe
but in terms of scalp health and um the
follicles then collagen is impactful
there but then from an athletic
perspective you know when it comes to
tendons ligaments cartilage muscle and
even bone collagen is a key protein and
so you know it's important to be able to
produce collagen the the the step that
doesn't make sense is just like you
don't have to eat mussels to gain
muscles right or eat brains to get
clever brains right that doesn't make
any sense you don't eat collagen to
build more collagen right and so it sort
of comes from some flawed studies in
rats collagen is simply a protein and
protein is basically a chain or like a
necklace if you can imagine of um amino
acids right imagine a necklace that's
got lots of different color dollars in
each color is representative of an amino
acid what your body does when it
consumes proteins it breaks the protein
down into its constituent amino acids
right and then your body just builds up
the types of proteins that it needs
including collagen
and so actually the meta-analysis review
on collagen 17 out of the 19 studies
were industry funded on top of that
um the the
um the product that was being supplied
wasn't just uh collagen it was collagen
with antioxidants with vitamins and
minerals right and with lots of other
things so you could never really
determine that it was a collagen itself
so the the hypothesis came from feeding
collagen to rats and seeing that the
collagen in some cases
um was bypassing the breakdown process
and making into the bloodstream right
um I'm not broken down and so there's
this hypothesis well maybe that then
makes it into the way where collagen is
needed
um so first of all that's not the case
in humans right and then second of all
we don't even know if in rats it
actually made it to where it meant to go
um furthermore we know that protein
itself just protein in general and
getting Mormon acids can be helpful for
collagen and skin right and and tendons
and ligaments and so it could just be
that if you eat a bit of collagen just
getting more protein but you could just
then eaten some beans or lentils or yeah
true and what we do know about
um collagen production is that it's
protein right that it's getting more
vitamin C where does that come from
plants right is um copper is important
in collagen production okay people on
plant-based diets get more copper than
people omnivorous diets and then there's
zinc and zinc is something you know
where plant-based eaters do get a little
bit less of usually and that's because a
lot of plant-based eaters don't eat that
healthfully right they eat a bunch of
processed junk food and so to get zinc
uh nuts and seeds
um greens and um whole grains right
nutritional yeast also those are going
to be you know high in zinc so if you
really want to you know if you're
worried about collagen production you
know protein vitamin C and copper which
you already get you can get easily on
plant-based diet and then uh zinc make
sure you're getting greens whole grains
uh nuts and seeds and maybe some
nutritional uses right yeah no that all
makes sense because I've seen I've seen
people do like a concoction where you
like add collagen and then you add like
a vitamin C source and then you add like
a certain instead of really just being
like if you eat a wide variety of whole
plant foods and you're getting all of it
yeah and I think it goes back to the you
know the same with animal Foods versus
plant Foods I say all or something I
think it's also important to of people a
bit of leeway within whole plant Foods
versus processed and process is pretty
gray word right because if I take an
apple I cut it in half I processed it
and then I cut it lots of pieces I
processed it and now I mash it up and I
make it apple sauce now it's processed
and I bake it or like I heat it up yeah
that's a process so I sort of like to
talk about refined more than like or
heavily in a process yeah the difference
of explaining it is like there's a big
difference right so I think with it all
or something it's again get a large
majority of your calories coming from
Whole plant foods and then you know if
you sometimes eat things that aren't
whole plant Foods I think that can be
fine yeah making that distinction is
pretty helpful because I think like
chopping up an apple and baking it into
you know as a product different process
right than like removing pot of rice
removing the fibers yeah or removing
certain yeah certain parts of rice or
you know refined grains and the ultra
processed foods or Ultra refined Foods
if you will like those are the foods
that have all these different refined
components and putting them together to
create this like Ultra addictive
concoction that's nowhere near in nature
the way we're supposed to be eating so
that's like a completely different thing
than like applesauce that's yeah Roundup
apples yeah exactly oh this is so
fascinating so I want to ask you then
what is next is there going to be like a
game changers 2.0 like what like I
mentioned we've got the game changers
Institute which is an inclusive research
education obviously
um uh platform an educational platform
and so we're doing a couple of things
there
um in fact people might be interested in
looking at a couple of the peer-reviewed
papers that we put out one is on the DS
protein scoring system and its flaws as
it relates to plant-based diets and as
it relates to the exercise performance
and you can look at that on through the
website gamechangersinstitute.com and
then there's another paper on Creatine
because that's another argument is like
hey well meat's got creatine there's not
creatine in a um in a plant-based diet
well first of all your body makes
creatine uh second of all there is a
benefit to having supplemental creatine
and we look at the difference between
supplemental creatine versus creatine
coming from meat and it shows that the
actual benefit is coming from
supplements so yeah uh it's it's kind of
a long paper yeah another time yeah it's
a lot it's a lot to go into a little bit
complex but
um it's probably that the
the detriment because again food's a
package right yeah so when create yeah
creatines and be great and protein to me
great what about all the other things
which could be offsetting it right yes
exactly um and so again that's you know
again
you've also got a way of athletic
performance versus Health right like
jacking loads and loads of protein might
be great for building as much muscle as
possible but it might actually not be
great for long-term Health right but
what is clear is if you are going to
have lots of protein it's much healthier
to get it from Plants
um so but those papers you know we're
putting out papers we're also going to
be putting out some um sort of
guidelines and educational pieces
through the game changers Institute
that's awesome well thanks for sharing
all that where can people find you so
they can continue following your work
and what you're working on yeah I mean
the so we have the on Instagram game
changers movie right my personal
Instagram is lightning Wilkes
um check out game changersmovie.com uh
and games institute.com and then the
nutrition brand uh will be launching its
own website and social media center as
well great thank you so much all right
we're going to end it here thanks for
coming on the show no thanks for having
me that was great
[Music]
foreign
[Music]